make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay so we are back with secret wars
2015. yes we are we are back with the
secret wars event and we have
thanos and the cabal fighting like 30
thor's
and here's the cool thing about this
right here's the cool thing about this
like
as soon as this whole battle goes down
we're kind of giving this this sort of
monologue
right from from steven strange right
stephen strange says here's something
you need to understand about how this
world is different from the old one
right the earth that was the universe
that was the multiverse that was
these were all formed by some higher
order some alien
ethereal other thing that perfectly
constructed not just the material nature
of everything
but the rules that governed it as well
but this world
this new world it was formed from the
shattered remnants of broken worlds
i know for i watched doom wheel them
into singularity if there's one thing
you hear
let it be this this new world is
unnatural
and survival is its first and highest
purpose
and that's the reality of this right the
the despite all the glitz and glamour
and despite like
all the different kingdoms and how
ordered and structured they may be this
battle between all these thors and
thanos
is the very nature of battle world right
that it really is just a place of
testing it's a terrible place to live in
only the strong really survive here if
you're too strong to rule a kingdom then
in turn your rule will be will be taken
over and you'll be subjugated by whoever
takes your place and if you try to fight
against it you'll be eliminated right
but it's one of these things where
only the weak are the ones who are ruled
and only the strong are the ones who do
the ruling and it's not so clear
cut is you know strong in in terms of
physical strength it's strong in
character strong and gumption are you
the kind of person that's capable of
getting things done or are you the kind
of person
who looks to others to do things for you
right to fix
problems to solve issues different
things like that you just kind of stick
your head in the sand and hope things
just get better
right that's the nature of what we're
talking about here now in terms of
physical brute force
all these stores are wrecked right they
they're they're totally wrecked
by by thanos and the cabal like they
just weren't prepared
that's all it is right but when you
switch back to doctor strange and you
pick up with like spider-man with peter
parker with miles morales you pick up
with jane foster thor you know all that
kind of stuff you basically have this
kind of explanation that's given because
reid asks
how did all this happen right how did
this take place like what led to this
and the explanation given to us by by
doctor strange kind of fills in uh
really a lot of the gaps between what we
saw at the end of hickman's avengers new
avengers and the beginning of now
and it released the sort of battle world
and what we're basically told is that in
the final moments of that battle right
in the final moments when doctor doom
molecule man owen reese and stephen
strange approached the beyonders
approached that fischer and when the
beyonders asked who they were
doom responded you know i am doom and
i'm the person who's going to end your
reign and they basically released all
those molecule men
on the beyonders and destroyed the
beyonders and wiped out pretty much all
the rest of the multiverse in the
process
that what this did is it left all this
energy for the beyonders out there right
left all the energy of the beyonders
just kind of sitting out there now we
don't know exactly what it was that took
place there in that moment but again
that's one of the things that hickman
does it kind of gives us these small
little tidbits here and there these
small little moments over the course of
the story but the response to stephen
strange is i
looked into what was basically
omnipotence the ability to do anything
that i wanted to to have so much power
that i could alter reality in virtually
any way that i wanted to and i turned
away from it right i was not ready for
that kind of power but doom
was and doom took that power and saved
all there was that was left to save
and now steven strain serves him and
that's the that's kind of the crazy
thing is because
what what you know when miles chimes in
and says like so so like everything like
everything is gone like all my family
all my friends
everything that i know and love is
completely and totally gone the response
of steven strange is not all of it right
some version
some small pit a bit of your new york
still exists right it still remains as
well as some small portion of wakanda
but keep in mind they're small
little pieces it's not the world that we
knew and that's what's kind of nuts here
the the the question is asked by cyclops
this is a really cool question here the
question that's asked by cyclops is
stephen strange
if you had the power if you had the
means to basically be the one who could
have played god and the world that you
have
is not the world you want then isn't it
your responsibility to burn it down
and raise up something better isn't it
if the world that you live in is not the
world that you want
isn't it your job to fix it isn't it
your job to basically do that that's the
burden that comes
with this kind of power right it's the
burden that comes with doom's power it's
the burden that comes with your power
that if you don't like the world that
doom created then your job is to undo it
your job is to challenge doom bring an
end to his rule
bring him down and make a better world
right and this on the surface is easy to
kind of look at this is just like a
comic book thing but that's true
even here in the real world right if we
don't like the world that we live in if
we don't like the environment we live in
whether it's the direction that the
country's going in or the direction that
your life is going in or the house that
you're living in or the relationships
the friendships all that kind of stuff
then it's your job
to fix it right it's not your job to
wait for someone else to fix it it's
your job to fix it and it's your job to
find a means to fix it
with other people if that's what it
requires right it's not your job
to rest on your laurels and just hope
that things get better right because
doing things changes things doing
nothing keeps things exactly as they are
and that's the whole point that cyclops
makes here is with this power that i
possess
then i will step up and i will do your
job for you right like if you are not
willing to challenge doom and bring him
into his reign then i will challenge
doom and i will bring an end to his
reign right so
the full power of the phoenix force and
that's what's kind of nuts about this is
remember this is an omniversal source of
energy this is a massive
source of power right right on par with
a living tribunal and so when that
happens in the midst of all this you end
up having one of these versions of thor
who basically uses his hammer to
essentially send an sos they call it to
prayer
right to you know praying to god but
basically it's a means to communicate
with god to communicate with doom
directly and to basically tell him
everything that's going on everything
that's happening and it's kind of nuts
because what's basically told here is
that there's chaos in the kingdom right
that the thor corps has been dispatched
and they are
they have called for reinforcements so
hundreds and hundreds of other thor's
are going to descend down on here but
with these few thors that are here the
the battle is going poorly and of course
you end up having you know
uh victor von doom you have susan storm
and these guys who basically end up
going to what's more or less projector
screen and watching all this take place
and doom initially
is kind of dismissive of it right it's
just kind of like well i mean you know
it's not a great big huge thing like the
thor core will ultimately prevail these
forces really can't be that strong but
between valeria and
susan we're given some pretty
significant information here
the first thing valeria says is there
are multiple versions of this thanos
character from across the multi or
across battle world right
each different universe you know we we
have some in some universes or some
kingdoms
we don't have one in other kingdoms but
despite all the different versions of
thanos that we have out there
this is the most powerful version that
i've ever seen the other part of this is
susan is just like look not even my
force feels can withstand that many
blunt that many attacks
from like a hammer of thor so this
person must be powerful right like this
guy max miss the mad he must just be
that powerful and so that's when
it's kind of like okay like you know
doom almost begins a process of saying
okay we need to get involved but then
steven strange shows up and when steven
strange arrives he brings his forces
with him the crazy thing about this is
that
watching all these different these
different people engage in battle
valerie's response is okay
like yes it seems more favorable and yes
it seems like the thor corps may have
another chance here or maybe it may have
a chance of success against these forces
but we don't know the power of these
guys
we don't know what level of power they
possess you know if we sent in
like a whole bunch of the malloids sure
we could sit in a thousand of them they
would get crushed just because you have
a higher number
does not mean that you have the
advantage it just means you have a
higher number right
all things being equal and so in turn
while that's going on susan
like directs you know victor von doom to
the monitor and says like that guy there
right the the guy in blue with the beard
like i don't know what it is about him
but like some
he feels different there's something
about him you know there's something
special about this guy
and so in response to that doom
basically says okay now it's time for me
to act because again what she's
referring to is reed richards right
this is the person that victor von doom
has been hunting for ever since he
recreated battle world he's been trying
to find
reed richards and so he basically says i
will return shortly
doom arrives on the scene and when he
does everything
stops all fighting stops and it's not
even because he makes them it's because
of his presence right the power of doom
like he shows up god has arrived onto
the battlefield and he immediately
addresses
reed richards and reed's response is
like this like this is really somewhat
of an amazing thing that you've done
here right an artificial construct of
reality a world where there should be
nothing like look at what you've made
this is a this is an incredible
achievement but the question i have to
ask here is what good have you done here
right like you put yourself on a throne
but like
what good have you done like what have
you done to make this world a better
place
have you just arrived here and you've
come into power and now you've made
things worse can you really call
yourself any measure of a leader at all
if what you've done is made this a
crappier place and the funny thing about
this is
doom kind of dances around and says like
i've always had a throne i've had a
throne for quite some time it's my
birthright i've placed myself a good bit
higher than that and thanos chimes in
and says
have you because if you have i have my
doubts because you don't refer to
yourself as god and if a person is going
to play god then they shouldn't shy away
from it and the response of doom is
i am god and then just unleashes on
everybody and essentially he's like like
literally just levitates him into the
air and says this is what a small
sampling of the power that i possess
i'm not even beginning to consider the
possibility of what it means to actually
try here
right like this is just that small that
infinitesimal amount of the power that i
have so i'm going to give you guys an
option you guys are going to bend your
knees right you're going to bend your
knee to my power and if you don't if you
don't recognize me as your god
then i will wipe you out and so from
there then you have the phoenix force
who steps in well you got cyclops who
steps in and says i don't need your
mercy i don't need to bend to your knee
i don't need anything of that of that
right i am a i'm a reality shaper i'm
the phoenix force i represent the sum
total of all life
that currently does has ever and will
ever exist and in the end
you're just like every other man right
playing at something greater than what
you are you are just a guy
right you're just a guy with an
incredible amount of power i am life
incarnate right i am what it means to be
alive incarnate the the source of life
energy itself and where he goes to melt
the helmet of doctor doom then suddenly
cyclops is ceased right literally seized
by victor von doom and when he says like
like where cyclops is going on this
grand speech about the future like the
future like this plan is yours no let me
help you understand something like the
future you dream of boy that dream
is dead that dream is over and he snaps
the neck of cyclops right just like
the entire phoenix force is obliterated
like just destroyed at the hands of
doctor doom
and the power he possesses while all
that's going on steven strange
sees the writing on the wall and he
tells he tells black panther over the
years that i've been here on battle
world i have
seen many things and i have hidden most
all of them but he says remember this
one thing remember what i'm doing here
remember this sacrifice that i'm making
today and he in turn
whisks everybody here all the like name
of the submariner thanos
t'challa all of them whisks them all
away and it's only him
and victor von doom and the question
that doctor doom asks is like where have
you sent them in a response of stephen
is i scatter them to the wind and then
when doom asks he says
why like why would you do that in
response to stephen is because we both
knew what was about to happen that they
would refuse
they would not bend their knee to you
they would not fall under your rule and
with that being the case you would
eliminate them
in with with extreme prejudice right you
would have killed them any and he tells
them like i haven't even told
reed richards about the fact that you
have susan storm and you have valeria
and you have franklin that you have them
here
right i haven't even told him that i
haven't told him any of that stuff
and when he when the when the demand of
of doom is call them back
the response to stephen is no and doom
says you will not
test me stephen and the response is even
strange is i'm sorry but i can't
right like at the end of the day you're
afraid of him right like you're afraid
of reed richards you're
like what do you think he'll do when he
found out about the life you stole
what do you think he's going to do at
the moment he's entertained at the
moment he's curious about all this but
neither you
nor i have really found and really
discovered what reed richards could do
if you put his mind to task on bringing
you down if that was his singular
one focus if that was his one thing and
that's the only thing that he wanted to
do was to bring you down
what would it look like imagine how hard
and how fast you would fall
if that was his one and only goal and so
having said that steven's like you are
afraid of reed richards and if i'm being
honest with you i think you
should be and with that insult flat like
steven strange
annihilated steven strange just killed
by victor von doom with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the raw core if you guys
enjoyed this video cliffhangers make
sure you drop a like and i will catch
you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you